good morning good morning everyone I
hope you're enjoying the conference
um let's talk about API security and
more specifically about getting API
security very wrong that's not a part in
the title but that's going to be the the
line chart the presentation I'm going to
show you how things go wrong in Real
World Systems plenty of stories and I'm
going to talk about getting things right
some guidelines some pointers and some
practical advice that you can use to
look at your apis and make sure they're
secure or even make them more secure and
the starting point here is a study from
about two years ago where a company
looked at a bunch of e-health apps and
they e-health apps well they handle
sensitive data by Nature there's no such
thing as non-sensitive e-health or
Healthcare information so it's
Healthcare information very sensitive
data and this study discovered like a
bunch of problems and one of these
problems is that a lot of these apps
about 30 apps they tested a lot of them
like 77 contained hard-coded API keys
and seven percent had hard-coded
usernames and passwords
that's not good have you ever followed
something about mobile security lesson
number one is typically like Hey
whenever you're doing something in a
mobile app in a front-end web app you
cannot put hard-coded secrets in there
because it's very trivial to get them
out people can decompile the app and
extract your secrets if it's JavaScript
they can just look at the JavaScript
extractor Secrets or they can just
monitor Network traffic and investigate
what you're including as a secret get it
out and abuse it that way so that's not
really great same study looked at the
apis Behind These systems as well they
looked at the apis and they discovered
that a lot of these apis are all of the
ones that they looked at had
authorization failures Bola attacks
broken object level authorization
that brings me to the very first
takeaway in this presentation already so
I have a whole bunch of takeaways in
case you're wondering the first one is
that it's time to take security
seriously or if you want to make it more
exciting the cowboy years are over as in
there's you can't really build an
application anymore and be like yeah I
will worry about security later because
guess what later is never gonna come
it's always like oh yeah we don't have
time now we have to build this feature
and that feature and by the time you're
actually getting to security it's
probably too late and it's going to be
insanely difficult to get this done
so the real takeaway is that you have to
ingrain security throughout your entire
development life cycle from the start
from day one you have to think about
security you have to build applications
to enable security doesn't mean you have
to do all the bells and whistle Security
First but at least think about how
things will evolve over time and set
yourself up for success that's
essentially what this means right here
all right
before we dive into the details let me
introduce myself I'm Philip Drake and
I'm a security expert and I did a PhD in
web security so I've been doing security
for quite a long time and since a while
now I run my own company called
pragmatic web security and through that
company I help developers build more
secure applications I teach workshops I
did a two-day conference Workshop right
here in NSC London I did one in Oslo
last week but I also do a quite a bunch
of In-House trainings where we actually
dive deep into security topics with
Developers do some Consulting highly
specialized Consulting on complex topics
or out open ID connect API security if
you work with these topics you know that
there's a lot of stuff you probably
don't know and you need someone to help
you explain that
all right I'm also a Google developer
expert and art zero Ambassador which is
always a bit confusing I'm not employed
by these companies but they like to
recognize the work I'm doing for the
community by having talks like this and
sharing articles and resources and so on
and they recognize that send me some
free swag in return and give me a nice
title and batch I can put on slides so
thank you for that our xeros here by the
way at the conference they have a boot
downstairs they have some cool swag that
they're looking to get rid of so if you
want to talk about authentication go
visit that boot downstairs all right
finally I organize a course in Belgium
it's a non-profit organization SEC app
Dev it's a course focused on secure
application development it's a week-long
course in Belgium so there's some
benefits to being in Belgium you can
figure out what those are but we also
bring in experts from around the world
to teach appsec one week so it runs in
June this year so look it up and make
sure you can be there if you want to
learn about appsec but enough about me
let's talk about security
let's talk about
the oasp API security top 10 very good
resource about figuring out what's going
wrong on apis if you know oasp it's a
non-profit organization aiming to
improve the state of web security and
they've been running this OS top 10 for
about two decades now it's a very
influential document to raise awareness
about the 10 most dangerous issues in
web applications but apis are slightly
different but not that much so they also
created a couple of years ago a specific
top 10 for apis
with some major issues you have to
investigate by the way the new version
of this one is coming out in the coming
weeks or months so there's going to be
an updated version
I haven't looked at the draft yet so I
don't know what's going to be in there
but I might have to update the slide
when it drops but I'm fairly confident
that the top issues are not likely to
change authorization failures number one
number five it's all about authorization
and we're going to talk about quite a
few of these things here in this session
all right first thing to talk about is
Bumble a dating app Bumble has is a
dating app using the traditional
freemium model so you can use Bumble and
you get some free features and after a
while if you swipe enough left and right
you have to pay them so they actually
make some money and so on and so on and
somebody looked at Bumble and
investigated how to implement these
restrictions and limits and it turns out
that they did everything in the front
end in a mobile app
so you could use a mobile app and you
were locked out or blocked from doing
anything else but if you knew how to
send API requests which a lot of you
will be able to do then you can still
access the API as if your account was
not locked or you didn't reach those
limits that's not good in case you're
wondering that's not good that's not
what's supposed to happen and this is a
very very common pattern that we see
over and over again like front-end apps
mobile apps and forcing certain
restrictions that are not enforced by
the API and forcing things like
transactional Integrity first we send
request one then request two and then
request three think about a webshop
fill your cart pay for your stuff ship
it to your home well if you can skip
step two
profit well at least for you not for the
web shop very illegal by the way so
don't do that but these things happen
quite often here's an example from
Twitter where they forgot or they send a
read notification from the front lines
which you could suppress so you could
read this is about fleets like a
temporary feature that they quickly
dropped after that never made it but
just to show you that these things occur
quite often
and this is something I often see when
talking to developers there's very often
security enforced in the frontland
without mimicking that behavior in the
back end and that is a problem because
attackers real attackers they don't give
a crap about your front end they don't
care about the mobile app they will use
a proxy sitting in the middle they will
use the app intercept traffic modify
requests and send them to their API in
the back end and they can do whatever
they want and if the API doesn't account
for that you are in a world of trouble
seriously this is not a good place to be
in so the client is irrelevant for
security
what the client does is good for user
experience and all of that stuff but the
real security is on the API on the
endpoints you expose that's where you
have to protect the application not in
the front end
of course the front end is not
completely useless so if you're also a
mobile developer don't worry your job is
not completely useless and of course we
have that as a window to the API but we
can also enforce security restrictions
in that mobile app in that front-end app
as long as we do the same thing on the
API
and then things get interesting because
if you enforce authorization or input
validation or whatever boats in the
front end and on the API
guess how often that should fail on the
API
never
it's there to protect you but it
shouldn't be triggered and that means if
it triggers if your API decides like hey
this user is not allowed to access admin
features why is this here in the first
place how did it get here either you
have a bug that would be my case I
probably screw at the front end but
since you're a good developers your
Frontline is going to be solid so
somebody's attacking your API so now you
have a high confidence signal that
somebody is tampering with the
application sending you stuff that is
never supposed to reach you and you can
use that to monitor the behavior of
attackers you can use that if you're
building sensitive applications you can
use that as a high confidence signal in
your security monitoring like something
is really wrong let's look at what this
user is doing let's keep track of that
or even if you want to take evasive
action let's block that user divert them
to a system with no sensitive data
whatever you want to do to actually fix
that so the real takeaway is that the
client is irrelevant to enforce security
enforcement is an API thing not a
clienting but the client can of course
Aid in the whole process by ensuring
that the same controls are also enforced
on the client
all right
back to our stories
grinder
had a security problem like so many
applications Grindr has user accounts
you can sign up with your email address
and so on and so on so like so many
applications they have a password reset
feature because well we suck at keeping
track of passwords and you know how a
password reset feature works right you
enter an email address so you go to
brand new Ender Philippe at pragmatic
web screw.com
and you submit that and I'll get a mail
in my mailbox with a unique link and
that link is like reset password with a
unique token that allows the user with
that link to reset the account ID
password from my account one time
if you fill it out you can't read my
mailbox hopefully otherwise I'm in big
trouble
but you can't read my mailbox so no
attack Factor there and the front-end
application if you enter an email
address is from the set like yeah we
send an email to that email address go
check your mail no attack Factor there
however
if you would inspect the actual Network
traffic you could see the request go to
the API and the response comes back and
it's like status success secret password
reset code something something
in the response in the Json data the
front that never shows it but the API
exposes it by accident that's a mistake
that was not supposed to be there if you
can look it up figure out how you use
the Network Tools like it's not a very
sophisticated attack you inspect the
network traffic in your browser look at
the response like a second tab you can
get the data and off you go
and with that token of course you can
reset the password from my account and
we again have a security vulnerability
and this problem is in the last API
executed then in spot number three if
you paid attention you knew what that
was if you didn't I'm going to tell you
so don't worry about that it's called
excessive data exposure because the API
is returning data to the front end at
the front that never uses and in this
case creates a significant vulnerability
and this is a really common problem
here's an example for the API security
swag shop whatever it shows a list of
online users
not sure if that's like really privacy
sensitive okay but whatever it shows a
list of online users so there's an API
call to the back end to get like get me
a list of online users and it returns a
set of Json information and we can
easily render that as an array in it's
not very sophisticated UI design I know
right but
straightforward right however in the
back end to get that list of users we
have some users somewhere users have
properties like addresses and that
information is just sent back in the
response this is extremely common
you want to know how common open up your
Dev tools and go to any application you
use stay in layout
open up your online bank and look at
what traffic they're sending back and
forth it's absolutely insane there's a
lot of information there
happens quite often
why does this happen how do we get here
well
in this particular case
it's because we're using a data class
somewhere in our system it's Java my
apologies for that but the benefit of
java everybody can read it never start
Java in your life I mean it's so verbose
it just basically tells you what's going
on so in this case we have a list of
online users we get that users we have a
list of actual user objects and users of
course have an ID and name and address
and so on and we just throw that in a
response like here's the list bam
response whoop out goes to Json we don't
construct Json by hand it just happens
automatically because otherwise our
lives would be living hell if you've
ever done Json by hand you know exactly
what I mean not fun so this is how this
happens right return users and off we go
data marshalling from objects to Json
very often leads to exposing sensitive
data
how can we fix that
well
there's a crappy solution and a good
solution
the crappy solution well it's not that
crappy but it doesn't really work at
scale the crappy solution is to use
annotations you can say like hey Jason
parser let's just pretend the field is
not here so we don't accidentally expose
this Jason ignore
it works but I'm not a big fan of that
because you can imagine it works for
like this super simple example on
PowerPoint but a real world application
of it like
dozens of these data classes going
through all the fields and adding
annotations left and right that's not
going to work very well and if you miss
one you have a vulnerability whoops
password recent token okay yeah yeah we
missed that annotation are bad and you
have a problem so a better approach is
to use this age-old pattern called data
transfer objects or a schema or whatever
works in your language because this
translates to different languages in
different ways but instead of returning
users directly we're now returning a
public user info object making things
very clear about what's going on what
are we returning public user info what
is public or an idea and a name like
yeah that makes sense
if you ever need to add a new field
well if you add a field like credit card
number to public user info that's on you
that's not a just a simple mistake you
make that's like I don't know Monday
morning code after heavy weekend of
spending in the pub something like that
but
this makes it very clear allows you to
review your DDOS and be like yeah that
makes sense and this actually explains
what's going on
all right automatic marshalling from
objects to Json results in excessive
data exposure number three in the top
10.
what if we flip it around
what if we marshaled Jason back into
objects can we then trick the API into
accepting data
and after building this anticipation the
answer is not no yes yes we can
otherwise it's going to be pretty like
oh no we can't I gotcha next one so this
is called Mass assignment this is the
same problem but the other way around
Mass assignment means that the user is
giving us data we're transforming that
data into an object to work with because
we don't want to deal with Json as a raw
value and that object makes its way
through the application to the data
layer and results in updates in the
database and this is supposed to be like
that there's a user class on the left
again Java we have a request on the
right to update my name my name becomes
Dr Phil
which I can actually do so that's pretty
cool so well I'm not sure if that's cool
but uh sure if you're old enough you
know what I'm talking about
I can send that request and update my
name that's a legitimate scenario and
everything goes well you have a unit
test that checks isn't always good
look at the class on the left let me see
yes my highlighter Works class on the
left has a role parameter guess what
that does that's used for authorization
purposes I may be a user in the system
so my role as user and that's it
so what if I send a request with like
additional Json properties what's going
to happen here in this case my name is
Philip becomes admin and my role is
admin and I sent this and the system is
like yeah I'm going to translate that
into a user object give it to the data
layer the data layers like which Fields
have changed oh the name update the name
oh the role updateral bam flip is now
admin Mass assignment
real world vulnerability leads to
massive problems account takeovers
changing prices of products in web shops
all kinds of nasty consequences
how do we fix this
annotations
we can do like access read only that's
it works like if you have one field this
is probably fine but if you do this at
scale in a real world applications this
is not going to work very well so you
use data transfer objects or schemas or
whatever works in your language you
basically restrict what information is
acceptable only a fixed set of fields
and now you have a very clear idea what
you're accepting and you can translate
that to what it means and update the
system correctly
all right the takeaway here is to test
your apis in their natural habitats as
in you have to test these things out
this is not something that screams at
you from code analysis like oh my God
this is wrong this is a very subtle
problem and doing code analysis doesn't
always reveal it especially Mass
assignments so you have to try this out
you have to test this write a test case
mess around temper with your own
requests and responses to see what's
going on and if you can make the API
misbehave
all right
that brings us to another question I
have a lot of questions in this
presentation even though there's no
interactivity so I just do it in your
head that might work the question here
is
is this really a good approach
like yeah you can test your apis and
maybe you can hire a pen testing firm to
test your apis and they'll tell you like
oh whoops excessive data here Mass
assignment there left right and so on
and now what
you can fix them that's step one
probably
and then you keep developing your API so
when are you going to test again
tomorrow well probably not especially if
you get the bill from a pen testing firm
that's not going to be for tomorrow
maybe next week next month well yeah
let's do it like twice a year
so in these six months you have nothing
it's called fingers crossed security
doesn't really work very well it's like
yeah things might work out but maybe
they don't so testing is useful testing
is good yes you can test this but it's
not a scalable approach that will allow
you to apply this in the real world
something that might work better
is using API contracts
if you specify an open API contract for
an API endpoint you are defining the
exact behavior that you want to see
I'm going to apologize again it's yaml I
know my apologies
but there's still support to help save
your space bar so you don't have to be
like running your spacebar the whole
time tools will actually help you write
these schemas but this is really really
useful because it defines the behavior
of the API it defines in this case the
exact response of that list of online
users and guess what's not their address
this is an ID and a name that's all we
really care about and that's what we
want to see in the response very clearly
defined
how do you use these things well
you write them
you can review them that's good
but the evolution that we're going
towards is having tools that use this as
input so that they understand your API
tools like fuzz Lightyear which you can
use for fuzzing your API it will send
you a whole bunch of requests and try to
make your API fail on certain inputs or
Microsoft has a tool called wrestler
that might do something that does
something very similar
that's one Suite of tools like testing
tools that understand where the inputs
go the format of the inputs and hey if
we give you a string where you expect an
integer do you actually fail
proper input validation proper checks
and so on and the second phase here the
Second Step what we're going towards is
actual enforcement at runtime you have
API gateways API firewalls that will
actually be able to take a schema as
input and actually enforce that on
incoming requests like API Shields from
cloudflare it's an Enterprise feature so
I haven't tried it because I don't have
an Enterprise plan but if somebody from
cloudflare is here just give me one and
I'll try it out for you that's uh that
might be awesome but cloudflare does
this 42 crunch is a company specifically
dedicated to this space they have an API
firewall that does this on requests and
responses automatically based on the
contract that's the takeaway here write
the contract
write your API to the best of your
abilities
and now you can map these things
together and make sure that API behaves
as you defined in the contract and if
you accidentally expose the password
reset token
the contract is not going to contain it
so you have a mismatch and you can
detect that or even fix it at runtime
all right
let me take a moment here and ask you a
question
who here is using API contracts
a handful of people all right
interesting
who here is using them for security
and not just for documentation
crickets nobody
if you're watching a recording like
literally nobody everybody's like crap
all right a couple of takeaways for the
people not doing API contracts
start doing that
why
not I'm not saying right like 15 pages
of contracts for all your apis but learn
how to deal with API contracts in the
real world this is not an easy thing it
seems like yeah I'll just write some
yaml and we're done no it isn't
the hard Parts keeping this thing in
sync with your actual implementation
because it's not like you write it once
you drop it somewhere and then you just
code your API because guess what if
something changes you have to update the
contract learn how to keep these things
up to date learn how to deal where they
best put the contracts what works really
well is like having code
in the endpoint implementation so you
can actually having documents sorry
having comments in your code so we can
keep these API contracts close to where
they are keep them up to date and so on
learn how to construct documentation
from that and deal with that in practice
one of the things you should not do well
at least for security documentation
purposes that's different but for
security you do not want to Auto
generate your contracts from your code
yes there's tools that do that and no
they're not very useful in this case
because guess what if you have since the
excessive data exposure or mass
assignment in your code and you ought to
generate a contract you'll have the same
vulnerabilities in the contract so you
gain nothing basically these tools are
built with documentation purposes like
create documentation from the
implementation which is also a bit I'm a
bit skeptical about that but that's not
how security Works in practice seriously
this might be the most important
takeaway from the entire presentation
look into using open API contracts
all right
got this really important
let's talk about authorization
let's talk about T-Mobile they've been
in the news recently because they had
another breach like whatever I've been
using this slide for a long time for me
because it's from 2017 but it highlights
the point very aptly and well let's say
that T-Mobile has had some issues since
then that they might have to deal with
but the problem here is that with
T-Mobile
my account information by contacting an
API Imports and the ID of my account is
my phone number
kind of makes sense it's a unique number
anyway so let's let's use that as an ID
sure why not
if I send that request they check if I'm
authenticated
good
and they get the account information and
they send me back the response
but if I want to get your account
information I send a requested API
substitute my phone number with your
phone number send it T-Mobile is like
are you authenticated like oh yeah you
are here's the account information
whoops they forgot about authorization
and this vulnerability used to be called
idor insecure direct object references
that's kind of the old crappy name the
better name is broken object level
authorization and this problem is
everywhere
remember that story from the beginning
slide number two
every single API of those Healthcare
apps had Bola vulnerabilities this
problem
and in India a while ago they built a
patient portal whoops a broken object
level authorization you could access
other patients information and with
Twitter they had a problem where you
could map phone numbers to Twitter
accounts and on Facebook they had a
problem where it could take control well
change the name of a Facebook page and
then register a new one with the old
name so everybody would come to your
page instead of the legitimate page
pays out 15 000 USD in bug Bounty so
this is not a small insignificant
vulnerability this is a real problem
that Facebook paid real money for for
reporting that
broken object level authorization
how do we get there what is it and how
do we get there well the starting point
of getting there
is this building in restful API in 10
minutes
I can tell you that in 10 minutes
there's not going to be any Security in
that API which is okay I'm not bashing
the tutorial here this is a fine
tutorial to learn about restful
principles in node.js
and it explains to you how to build a
take a wild guess what application we're
going to build
it's a two application yes tasks because
everybody has tasks like always tasks by
the way in my trainings I use restaurant
reviews because I like good food and I
hate desks so it kind of works out well
for me
that said if you want to build a restful
API to delete the task you send a delete
request to the application like the HP
method delete you handle that you get a
task ID you find the task you drop it
from your database and you're done
that's what you learn in a tutorial like
that and that's exactly how rest apis
work
and if you've done that you're like okay
I got that awesome
let's add
security you're going to add
authentication that's going to be the
next step your follower tutorials
somewhere on the Internet is going to be
like building authentication node.js in
10 minutes and you can follow that one
and you will get somewhere that says
requires off good
if you're T-Mobile at this point you're
like job done bye bye next
you can cross off the task if you're
someone else you might want to think a
bit further like authenticating the user
is good but how do I know that they can
delete tasks maybe we need to add some
authorization so we check has permission
delete task that makes perfect sense
right
because maybe only Philip is allowed to
delete tasks but not the other user at
this point we have implemented
function level authorization we already
fixed number one of the OS API security
top 10 issues number five is now fixed
function level authorization good
awesome good job
T-Mobile you that's
I'm gonna get in trouble for this but I
will deal with that later
what we haven't fixed
is object level authorization how do we
know if you're allowed to delete tasks
how do we know you're deleting the right
tasks what if you want to delete my
tasks are you allowed to do that well
that requires you to look at the actual
task and the user and the permissions
and so on to deal with that
and that is broken object level
authorization and that problem exists in
a lot of apis but we'll talk about that
in a second first the takeaway here's
and force authorization at the function
level that's a good thing that's
something you have to do and to be
honest that's something that a lot of
apis actually get right as well it's not
too common to see completely no
authorization at all it happens but not
that often
that's good
let's take a side track here before we
talk about object level authorization
let's look at authorization in general
here's two requests on top you have one
for getting tasks and at the bottom you
have one for deleting tasks all right
the top one
has no authorization logic here the
bottom one has a permission check for
deleting tasks function level
authorization
good
is this correct or not
I don't know
I'm often in this position where I'm
working with a team I'm improving their
security and we look at authorization
logic and I'm like
is this correct and I have to ask like
is this do you actually intend that
getting task is probably accessible I
can everybody see a list of tasks maybe
it's like a super accountable task
manager where everybody can see the
stuff you have to do then I don't know
or maybe somebody forgot authorization
the fact that we can't see it is the
fact that you have to look at this
snippet of code in me like yeah I don't
know if that's supposed to be like that
or not that means this policy is not
easy to audit
it doesn't scream at you that this is
either a mistake or probably accessible
it's like oh yeah this is a subtle
detail something is missing and because
of that everybody can access this
endpoint
what if we make everybody's life easier
by doing like just a little bit more
effort we can do something like this
allow Public Access
guess what if this was not supposed to
be the case and you look at your API
code now or you bring me in to help you
with that I'm going to be like why the
hell is that endpoint public
you'll be like oh yeah whoops I don't
know it's but it's not gonna happen
because you'll see that you'll see that
immediately if you look at the code that
something is really wrong here or you
see that this is actually intentional
instead of just an oversight and this
takeaway is so important Empower
auditability because the security of
your authorization policy is completely
dependent on your power of other things
the policy because if you can't review
it how the hell do you know that it does
what it's supposed to do
again we're back to fingers crossed it's
like yeah it's probably good
for likely it isn't all of the
healthcare apis had Bola vulnerabilities
I don't know the details but I'm fairly
certain that a lot of those policies
were impossible to audit
really really important
all right let's go back to Broken object
level authorization why is that issue so
common because it's a nightmare to
actually enforce
here's an example of what you'll end up
with and I'm not joking I see this code
in different contexts of course I don't
review to do applications but in
different contexts I see code like this
all the time
clue is on line number four like yeah we
check functional level Access Control
delete task the user has this permission
and then it's like oh if you're an admin
or a manager like yeah you're allowed to
do that but if you're not if you're like
a regular employee or a regular user you
can only delete your own tasks so now
the fun starts like oh if the user is
this then we have to check that and
again auditability of this is an
absolute Nightmare how do I know that
you covered all cases I don't it takes
very intricate knowledge about the
business domain to assess whether this
endpoint is implemented securely and I
don't really like that
so how can we improve this
how can we fix this well
first step or an important step is
pulling that authorization logic out of
the application so instead of doing
everything in the API what if we put our
authorization logic separately
your developers your engineers I can
already see you overthinking this I can
see you thinking like oh yeah we can
probably find a service that handles no
no
the simplest version of doing this
is using one code file
you copy the logic you move it into an
authorization policy JavaScript module
or Java class with static methods or
whatever you're doing and you ask can
delete task
very simple very straightforward very
under engineered by the way by Design
because everybody can do this it costs
you zero money for vendors it costs it
doesn't require you to spin up a
separate service to run a separate
product to find something that suits you
all it takes is writing a few lines of
code and that's it and this gives you
massive benefits
first of all if I have to review
something like this I can say
very fast like yeah this makes perfect
sense
the leading tasks you check the
authorization policy good I'm not saying
that your transition policy is correct
I'm saying the endpoint code is Rock
Solid awesome
second step in this would be evaluating
the optimization policy does this thing
do what you wanted to do according to
your business rules and it's now
centralized so you have one file you
have to review awesome you have one file
you can unit test you can unit test your
actual policy without having to deal
with endpoints and requests or responses
you can just write a set of unit tests
you can apply source code control on
that file like somebody you can log the
file and nobody is allowed to update the
authorization policy by accident
I've seen it as well PR's like a pull
request where somebody's like yeah I'm
gonna change something here and delete
this part of authorization logic because
I don't think it's necessary and Bam
vulnerability
this will help fix that
so this makes your code
a lot better
well at least line four makes your code
better not just the sad face as
exception handling that's not a very
good way to handle errors on line seven
so don't do that but take the relevant
Parts here line number four
and yes
let's bring you back to the engineering
part yes you can make this better you
can Implement some centralized Services
you can Implement things like a policy
engine where you use a service to handle
your authorization logic but that's for
complex use cases if you have like a
really Advanced policy writing an encode
is not going to work very well anymore
so you can use tools like open policy
agents like an Oso like so many startups
are building now this is a Hot Topic in
startup World fixing authorization this
will be possible but the first step is
centralizing it yourself and then if
you're like yeah this thing is becoming
too big to really manage let's push it
out to a separate service that is
perfectly possible as well
keep taking away your centralization
either in code or as a service whatever
floats your boat you can have various
degrees of complexity here but this is a
better way than having it scattered
throughout the code
because it allows you to audit the
policy and allows you to test the policy
to control who changes it and it will
make things better in the long run trust
me on that one
all right
what else do we have well
I make it sound like there's a choice
but there really isn't it's like a
sequential set of slides so I
where do we how do we make authorization
decisions well we talked about the
specifics but we have we have to get the
user information somewhere right the
user typically authenticates to the
Apple to an authentication Service
somewhere or an authentication endpoint
once we don't authenticate every time we
don't provide the user details on every
well the user's authentication details
on every request we do it once and now
we propagate authentication state
some people are old enough to remember
the concept of session management like
whoa 30 sessions well 30 sessions is one
way of doing that you can have a Chase
session ID it points to a Java session
server-side object keeping track of
information for this specific session
this specific user and we can keep track
of the user's authentication State and
their roles and their permissions and
whatever we want to keep track of
and this mechanism is beautiful
I'm not joking here this is actually
beautiful this is a secure service and
environment nobody can really go into
the server and modify values in memory
or in your cache or whatever you're
keeping that
this
is a solid place to store that data yes
it has some drawbacks
no it is absolutely not an invalid
pattern for apis you can use that in
modern applications in fact this better
is well supported in many platforms
Heroku where you can deploy cloud-based
applications has built-in session
support for Java using a redis cache
is it completely stateless like the
major applications are doing like you
built Facebook or Netflix no it isn't
does it work well for an application
with a few hundred or a few thousand
users yes it does beautifully and it
will make your life
extremely easy because you don't have to
worry about pushing data to the client
about whether you can trust that data
when it comes back and how you secure it
how you revoke an active session how you
log in user out and all of that stuff
magically solved by server-side sessions
yes they're ugly in some respects yes
they are not infinitely scalable but for
many applications this perfectly
suffices
I can't tell you how often I have the
case where a customer is building a new
app and you're like yeah we want to make
the stateless and use shots that we push
to decline and this and that but we have
these and these challenges like yeah of
course you do
and my question is how many users do you
have like yeah we have in this case it
was a very specific application for the
customers we have like 50 to 100 users
like what the hell are you doing
run that with a server-side session on a
single server and it's going to work
beautifully and you want load balancing
that have two which Azure replication
it's going to work beautifully saves you
a whole bunch of headaches and this
actually saved them a couple of days of
time in building that simple application
just by using proven Concepts and the
takeaway here is that traditional web
sessions people will tell you that apis
can never use cookies and they're wrong
as proven by half of the internet
actually traditional web sessions are
still valid they make your life
extremely easy and sometimes you don't
need to push it to the extremes
but sometimes you do and when you do
there's a whole bunch of approaches you
can use there's some custom token
mechanisms there's a very wrong way of
doing it the more better way of doing it
and then there's the state of the art or
the best practice of doing it using
oauth
using oauth is not going to make your
life easier it's going to make your life
harder significantly harder to bid on to
be honest starts with figuring out which
spec you need to read because there's
like a dozen that overlap and deprecate
stuff and add new stuff and trust me
I've been there for a long time this is
not an easy approach but it has benefits
because in a lot I'm just going to give
you a quick rundown of how it works I'm
not going to dive into detail we don't
have that much of time that much time
here but in oauth clients our users
authenticate to an authorization server
not the authentication server but the
authorization a lot of stuff anyway
centralized handling of credentials and
client authentication and so on and
afterwards they conduct apis with access
tokens
and that access token represents the
authority of the client to act on behalf
of user or as a client directly to the
API and allows the client to handle
other API to handle authorization
awesome
if you're an API developer now you're
happy right tokens oh thank God the
stuff about sessions what the hell was
that about
tokens now everybody's happy good
did you know that oauth has two types of
tokens
you have
somebody's nodding yes good you have
reference tokens and you have
self-contained tokens here's how a
reference token works so a reference
token is called an access token but it's
basically just like a random ID it
doesn't contain anything and it points
to State kept by the authorization
server server side state so even in
oauth you have tokens that represent a
session ID we just call them an access
token because we don't want to call them
a session ID but they represent the same
thing as a session ID when the API
receives that they will have to do token
introspection a process where you go
back to the authorization server ask
like hey I got this ID what does that
mean oh yeah here's a bunch of claims
thank you and now you can make
authorization decisions that's one mode
of operation very very similar to
server-side session management with the
same Security benefits and the same
drawbacks
just so you know even with modern
state-of-the-art approaches we still
have server-side state because it's a
valid concept
of course all the cool kids are doing
Json web token so you can also have
access tokens in the format of a Json
web token where the client gets a jot
the job contains all the claims you send
that job to the API and the API can
verify the signature get the claims out
and use those claims to make
authorization decisions obviously Better
scalability Properties
because now there's no direct link to
the API and the authorization server
there's no heavy communication there and
apis can validate tokens independently
but this approach has some revocation
issues they should be short-lived so
because you can't really terminate
tokens proactively and so on just so you
know that these things exist
the takeaway here
is basically that you want to analyze
your security requirements carefully
because sometimes you don't need to go
full overboard with things like oads and
sometimes you don't want to use Json web
tokens but want to use reference tokens
and sometimes you'll have to decide and
the trade-off is going to be not that
clear and you'll have to accept certain
risks in favor or in exchange for
certain benefits or not and the other
way around
that's a very important takeaway
we've been talking about Json web tokens
now so I have to say a couple of things
about that
Jason web tokens are a mess there's a
whole bunch of security pitfalls and
vulnerabilities and things to take care
of and I don't have the time to talk
about them
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
give you two references one is a spec I
know everybody loves reading RFC so
that's good news because this is an RFC
number 8725 if you want to know but it's
a very consumable RFC it's about Json
web tokens and has two meaningful
sections there's like the introduction
which is whatever section one
problems with jaws like just a list with
some explanation section two
fixing jars like recommendations with
explanations that's it there's no weird
ascr diagrams and stuff like that it's
just like hey here's some problems
here's some best practices follow them
thank you
if you like to read prettier content
I've also written an article about Json
web token security pitfalls last a year
and two months ago so that might be a
bit more consumable than RC we have some
nice pictures and so on and so on I
don't care what you read this is just
some pointers but read up on job
security make sure you avoid these
common pitfalls
all right follow jot security
best practices
that brings us close
to lunch I know
people are anxious like oh come on I'm
hungry are we done done yet almost
almost
I have another question to ask yes
another one what happens when poo goes
wrong I'm being recorded here so I have
to be careful what happens when
something goes wrong
far too often when something trivial
goes wrong
everything breaks
when something trivial goes wrong here
it means like a full system compromise
and that makes no sense at all
why on Earth are we running like super
unsecure features alongside the main
application alongside super trusted
features like user authentication and
stuff like that like what the hell are
we doing compartmentalize your apis
they're easy to say in PowerPoint like
yeah just split them up like untrusted
stuff here and have some boundaries and
then the main application apis like and
then some boundaries and then the highly
sensitive services
that's the awesomeness of my job I just
have to draw some lines on the slide I'm
like dumb you do that I know this is not
easy to do in practice I know this is
not trivial and that's why we often
don't do it but this is your only
fighting chance to stop an attack from
fully compromising your backend services
this is what we need to do to try and
contain the out file of an attack
because some vulnerabilities are gonna
exist and somebody's gonna exploit them
at some time
and if it happens in this super
unimportant search feature in your
application you want to be able to tell
your customers like yeah we had a
problem well best case is we had a
problem we don't nobody nothing was
compromised so we don't even have to
report it that's good and otherwise it's
like yeah we had a problem but guess
what none of your data was compromised
did you ever get an email like that no
of course not
but this can help you
getting there compartmentalization is
really important to reduce the impact of
a vulnerability and yes it's a pain and
no it's not something you just decide in
five minutes and do it but it's
something you have to work towards in
practice
and that light I have one more topic to
talk about and that is using web
application firewalls or API firewalls
or API gateways and so on we've been
using these devices for a long time as
like a first line of defense
I always run into them when I do
cross-at scripting in my workshop
because people are on a corporate
networks and they do access attacks on
the demo of the training application and
the firewall is like uh-uh you can't do
crosstrypting
then I tell them like here's how you get
around that which is so not questionable
but no offense the WAFF that they're
using is probably pretty stupid so it
doesn't really account for much but
there's a change here there's a change
in API based systems that we're trying
or not trying we're moving towards using
these devices as actual defenses you can
find API gateways that do things like
rate limiting
or authentication or API gateways that
will do enforcement of contracts on
requests and responses and that means
that they're no longer no longer a first
line of defense but they're deep defense
for some things the only line of defense
and that's by itself not a bad pattern
that's good we can do that that's what
these products are for
but it also means one very important
thing you have to make sure the attacker
can't get around that waft that Gateway
that firewall
I have a good image to illustrate that
you're not supposed to implement an API
Gateway like that that's not very good
might work in the UK because it's going
to be mother nobody can get through it
but in the rest of the world it doesn't
rain that often so it shouldn't it
should be fairly accessible
but seriously
this is a real problem modern systems we
call those apis let me skip back here we
call these applications these apis the
origin servers the actual service
handling requests and they're not
supposed to be exposed to the internet
you have to make sure that there's no
path around that gateway to access the
origin server directly and this is
something that comes up quite often in
vulnerability reports or in penetration
testing reports and so on because once
the attacker figures out where the
origin server is they can access it
directly guess what no rate limits so
all of these brute forcing things that
you thought were covered are no longer
covered like MFA codes like four digits
or six digits well brute forcing that is
not that hard bam oops all of his stuff
these things going wrong so the takeaway
here is make sure that if you rely on
perimeter level security
for the actual security of your
applications that it's not bypassable
that there's no path around it try to
hide origin servers
which is not easy by the way so assume
that the attacker will always discover
where the actual origin server is and
make sure the account access it and if
they can access it move the defense
closer to the API
if that's your deployment model where
you're like yeah we can't prevent this
from happening then guess what you can't
do perimeter security because you have
to do it closer to the API that's the
final takeaway here so now it's up to
you my part is done I told you what to
do so now you enjoy the rest of the
conference first and then on Monday you
pick one of these topics and you do them
that's how you improve security it's not
like like oh yeah that was interesting
and then do nothing and the same thing
all over again no you take one of these
things my recommendation
look at your authorization policy open
up your API look at your endpoints and
see
to stand what's going on here can I tell
if this is a secure policy if the answer
is no
well maybe try again on Tuesday because
I don't know what happens on Monday in
your world but if you can't tell this
improve it your policy is not auditable
enough refactor it to make sure it
becomes more clear apply what we talked
about here write security tests to
verify your authorization improve your
job handling build open API
specifications there's so many takeaways
use that information later on to
review your systems all right if you go
to my website you'll find the slides
there as well if you want to learn more
hire me for a security Workshop I can go
into plenty of detail on each of these
topics if you want to I have some online
courses as well on my website so you can
look at that
and with that I basically want to say
thank you for being here thank you for
listening thank you for staying which
usually is not a problem so that's good
um
I hope you enjoyed it and we have a few
minutes for questions if you're not too
hungry there's a mic up front so you can
come up front ask your question so it's
also on the live stream and then
afterwards we can enjoy lunch thank you
[Applause]
are there any questions
yes
yeah in a few words what's uh option uh
if we can't hard code API keys in the
client how do we
make sure that the client has access to
it
yeah it depends on the clients what that
means if your client runs on a user
device then no you can't hard code it
because they will get it out anyway if
your client runs in a secure environment
such as a server-side application you
can provide that through environment
variables or whatever comfy so that's
server-side environments easy to handle
user device is not that easy
very often user
clients running on user devices they
only need access on behalf of a user you
don't really care which client it is you
care which user it is so in that case
the user would follow an authentication
step and the client would get a some
form of token representing that
authentication and can use that one to
authenticate calls to the API if you can
do that then the whole problem goes away
because you don't really need to
authenticate a specific client just the
user using the client
and then for client-specific
authentication if you really want to do
that on user devices it involves
generating a secret on the device and
then having a registration step where
you shared it with the API so for
example a mobile app could generate a
keeper and then register itself with the
API through under registration endpoint
which is unprotected but that's how it
is like hey I'm this client here's my
public key and whenever I sign something
with my private key you know it's me and
then you can associate identity with
that and you can use that for
authentication a registration step in a
corporate setup that typically is
something where you have to register
your device once with like a code you
get from somewhere you copy pasted
something stuff like that could work as
well scanning QR codes that's that's how
you do it you generate secrets on the
device and use a registration step to
link the client to the secret on the API
and from that point on you have your
Authentication
awesome
that was a good question thank you for
that
anybody else
well you can always grab me during lunch
because I'm also hungry so I'll see you
downstairs enjoy the conference
okay